I think this girl made a big impression
at the press conference right here who
is she
let's listen to her she's a she's
beautiful she's a regular girl
yeah we've taken back control a New York
I run New York II a [ __ ] pimp his
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] so good I
wonder what goes on at Dana's head one
of yours and put out alright I'm fresh
ready to go I look forward to I'm gonna
shoot this man Oh trust me on that
I have to imagine you get hit pause for
a second Adrian I have to imagine that
dana loves this because this is what
this is what got it's on TMZ [ __ ] its
people up this really make people who
don't watch the sport want to know who
this [ __ ] is and why is he doing he
has brought eyeballs to this sport yes
that have not been brought away Ronda
brought female eyeballs and other
eyeballs to the sport when I walk around
and and the talk that I get from people
and people I know that never even
watched the UFC and they're talking to
me about Conor McGregor that's a game
changer Conor McGregor is a game changer
he's a household name and there's not
that many household names I said a while
back that he will be the first fighter
in UFC to earn a hundred million dollars
and Wow and then I remembered that
Lorenzo Fertitta came out and said the
same thing a week or so later and I
right now I think the figure he's almost
at 40 is easily gonna be a hundred
million by the end of I would say not
next year but the year after 20 he's
been clean a bit though I don't know
kind of I hear he has quite a fun life
that's where you got to be careful but
you know I think it's mink expensive
because he said he's got a mink coat you
wonder if he bought that if it's just
I'm alone you hope did you hear that I
did because he had the tags hanging from
it when I walked in Al Gore says he goes
you rented that guy receipt in the
pocket on his prophet Conners making so
much money I would venture to guess that
aside from you know I I don't see him I
see him is spending a lot of money on
his clothes yeah his flash and his bling
but hopefully unlike other athletes that
we've seen and let's face it 85% of them
go broke five years after they retire I
hope that does not happen to Connor and
he's making so much money you got to be
an idiot to spend that much money but
honestly like the money that he spends
on clothes
is an investment in that like you know
you want to think that a fighter is just
gonna get paid strictly for their
performance in the Octagon but the fact
of the matter is part of him getting as
many eyes as he gets on the show and
being responsible for his many
pay-per-view buys as he is is that flash
factor no question but you know again we
get back to branding okay he's branding
himself this is his brand yeah stop with
that he gets into New York and he has
two rolls-royce's one with his name on
it you know we're on the car is his name
it's right it's just under Tory us right
on the whole side of the car was a
personalized Oh Royce and put his face
on it yeah put his face on his face is
all over the back door
it says notorious see it right there Wow
so across the entire it's the it's the
left side of the car across the entire
side of the car it says the word
notorious and then there is a giant
Conor McGregor face right at the back of
the of the back that's bad that's bad
though cause everybody's gonna know it's
you you know how much I would hate to
have my face on the side of my car
they'd be like why is Jim Norton riding
around the same block let me tell you a
couple things why why I respect Conor
McGregor's so much you know back in I
think it was Dublin I did a show years
ago right and this young like 19 year
old kid comes up to me no beard and he
goes my name is Conor McGregor
remember it you're gonna be announcing
me someday okay okay great I get that
all the time right the guy had the
fortitude and the foresight to get to
worry he believes in himself that
confidence we were talking Commodus
factor is huge and Conor is a very
intelligent young man he's sharp
you know that he's not so much rehearsed
as as others like I think Chael Sonnen
was a great trash talker but he's
rehearsed yeah he's not rehearsed
I mean channel Simon was literally doing
the rest of the Pro Wrestling promise
that he saw when he was a kid he's
brilliant Andy was bringing into the
Octagon he was great yeah but that's
what he was doing we really were hard
she didn't feel rehearse to be I guess I
just did
I'm sure I guarantee that a few of those
lines out of child's mouth were practice
the night before I have no doubt about
it you can find him on YouTube like that
like the wrestlers that did them in the
70s you're not taking anything away from
jail because chose brilliant what he did
but Connor brings that whole it's it's
like everything goes to a next level
Connors the next level yeah he just
announced the Irish we're taking back
New York like it was Gangs of New York
I've never heard a fighter threaten said
put your bag in somebody else's mouth
yeah let's listen to some more the press
kept really great he's really awesome
Alvarez could be besaid that hear it he
helps you win the fight so you won't
dock them if you win do you have any any
ideas on what's next for you if you do
beat Connor after I beat Connor and
silence the country Ireland I'll have a
couple of pina coladas you ought to look
for me somewhere Eddie does a good job
but it's so hard to match confident yeah
yeah I'll take all them bills over there
it's hilarious
just moving weight class to weight class
it's weird because I'm watching this I
like Eddie Alvarez a lot it's like I
kind of want to see him really flatten
you do oh yeah I just don't want to
sound stupid oh honey I don't want the
talking to stop ever
well the talking will never stop he lost
an idea as the talk shop now that's a
good point you're dealing with the
toughest fighting arena in the world the
proving ground of champions beyond any
other ring or square ring or whatever is
the Octagon for fighters okay not the
boxes aren't fighters they're boxing
these are fighters getting in there
using every form of fighting there is
it's just this what it is